yep the junos are singing charlotte
carden's praises the 27 year old
songstress earned six nominations making
charlotte this year's top nominee
how does it feel to be the most
nominated artist at this year's journal
it feels
completely surreal i'm just very
overwhelmed and excited this is really
wonderful the montreal native is up for
album of the year single of the year and
artist of the year thanks to her debut
lp phoenix
hot on her heels racking up five
nominations each for the weekend and
justin bieber
yeah these two will duke it out in four
major categories including fan choice
and single of the year i wonder
what it's like to be my friends
meanwhile shawn mendes naps four
nominations as does first-time nominee
jessia thanks to the success of her
viral smash i'm not pretty maybe i'm
just fine did you think that that song
would take you to the places it has so
far
no but i'm so glad that it did
[Laughter]
i'm so unbelievably proud of that song
and
yeah it just keeps on doing amazing
amazing things and checking off the
bucket list so it's more than i could
ever dream of tied with jesse and sean
sick side rapper presa whose four
nominations include breakthrough artist
of the year and rap album ep of the year
for gardner express and toronto's jp sax
joins sean justin charlotte and the
weekend in the coveted artist of the
year category the nominations i think
are validating that 17 year old kid
in
you know northern toronto dreaming about
being a singer-songwriter surrounded by
people who are getting into fancy
colleges wasn't totally ruining his life